hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ztf heute
live wer von euch auf die Bahn
angewiesen ist der oder die hat in den
letzten Tagen bestimmt schon mit
Sicherheit viel Zeit mit alternativen
Planungen verbracht denn es wird
gestreikt seit heute morgen geht fast
nichts mehr die Gewerkschaft der
Lockführer GDL streikt mal wieder muss
man sagen und so sieht es zurzeit auch
an den Bahnhöfen aus wir haben Bilder
und auch hier von den Streiks und
diesmal soll der Streik besonders lange
dauern sechs Tage lang das wäre damit
dann der längste Streik in der
Geschichte der Deutschen Bahn denn nach
einer Einigung sieht es auch einfach
nicht aus der Zeit dieser Streik der
soll weh tun er hat auch Auswirkungen
auf die Wirtschaft neben dem
Personenverkehr steht auch der
Güterverkehr still muss das sein geht
dieser Streik zu weit das ist heute die
Frage bei uns und ihr könnt da gerne
mitdiskutieren Fragen stellen oder
einfach auch ein Kommentar schreiben
macht das gerne ger per Mail oder im
Stream direkt und wir reden jetzt am
Anfang der Sendung zu zunächst direkt
mit jemand der den Streik naturgemäß
unterstützt und der sich aber auch mit
den Anforderungen und der
Arbeitsbelastung in dem Job auskennt es
ist svenn Schmitte er ist selbst
logführer und er ist Bezirksvorsitzender
der GDL in Nordrhein-Westfalen und uns
jetzt aus Düsseldorf zugeschaltet hallo
schönen guten Abend Herr Schmitte schön
guten Abend Frau jung ganz kurz um reiß
ich mal worum es geht für alle die das
nicht so parat haben also sechs Tage
Streik keine Einigung in Sicht worum
geht's ein zentraler Punkt sie die
logführer Gewerkschaft GDL will eine
reduzierte Wochenarbeitszeit für
Schichtarbeiter von 38 auf 35 Stunden
bei vollem Lohnausgleich das ist ein
zentraler Punkt es gibt auch noch
weitere Punkte und die Bahn die bietet
das so nicht an sondern ein Modell mit
37 Stunden warum sind sie wenn es da
jetzt aber ein ein Angebot gibt aber
direkt auch aktuell gar nicht mehr
verhandlungsbereit warum direkt der
Streik ja direkt der Streik ist ja schon
nicht ganz richtig wir haben ja
Tarifverhandlungen die laufen schon
etwas länger die Angebote sind schon im
letzten Jahr
abgegeben worden also die Tarifforderung
es gab Vorgespräche mit der Deutschen
Bahn zur Erläuterung der Forderung man
hat also schon zusammengesessen und hat
relativ schnell vom Vorstand der
Deutschen Bahner geben man muss ja hier
ein bisschen trennen um welches
Unternehmen es geht schnell gehört was
denn alles nicht geht und was alles aus
Sicht der Deutschen Bahn nicht
verhandelt werden soll und da gehörte
nicht nur das Thema Absenkung der
Arbeitszeit hinzu auch das Thema F Tage
Woche also fün Tage arbeiten zwei Tage
frei sollte nicht verhandelt werden
sowie das Thema Abschluss von
Tarifverträgen für unsere Mitglieder in
den Stellwerken oder in den
fahrzeuginstandhaltungsbereichen genau
es gibt in der Tat natürlich mehr Punkte
um die es noch geht wir wollen es jetzt
auch mal genauer aufdröseln wir haben
einen Beitrag vorbereitet über die
Forderungen im Einzelnen über den Status
Quo auch die Frage was verdienen
loogführer denn aktuell Christian Volk
hat den
vorbereitet in den vergangenen Jahren
sind die Gehälter bei der Bahn für für
GDL Mitglieder deutlich gestiegen seit
2014 um mehr als
21%. aber auch die Verbraucherpreise
legten zu umfastst 25% damit konnten die
Löhne nicht mithalten der Vergleich zu
anderen Branchen zeigt auch dort stiegen
die Gehälter zuletzt sogar deutlich
stärker als bei den GDL Tarifen
durchschnittlich verdienen
lockführerinnen und Lockführer etwas
mehr als 50.000 € pro Jahr damit liegen
sie unter dem deutschen Durchschnitt von
rund6 50.000 € verdienen weniger als
Lehrer aber mehr als
Maurer der Lohn sei zu gering sagt die
GDL die Verantwortung für Fahrgäste groß
die Arbeit oft anstrengend deshalb
fordert die Gewerkschaft vor allem eine
kürzere Wochenarbeitszeit für
Schichtarbeiter von 38 auf 35 Stunden
bei vollem Lohnausgleich das Angebot der
Bahn es gibt eine Wahlmöglichkeit
entweder 37 Stunden bei gleichem Lohn
oder 38 Stunden mit einem Plus von
2,7%. Voraussetzung die Bahn findet
ausreichend
Personal jetzt haben wir es noch mal
detailliert gehört weniger als Lehrer
mehr als Maura warum sagen Sie was macht
ihren Job so viel verantwortungsvoller
oder so verantwortungsvoll dass sie das
jetzt auf jeden Fall durchbringen
möchten es geht ja jetzt auch erstmal
nicht nur marginal um den Beruf des
lokomotivführers äh wir verhandeln als
GDL für alle eisenbahnerinnen und
Eisenbahner direkten Bereich
unser Name der ist 150 Jahre alt der
suggeriert dass wir ausschließlich für
Lokomotivführer unterwegs sind aber wir
verhandeln ja für Zugbegleiter
bordgastronomen Ausbilder Disponenten
Fahrdienstleiter fahrzeuginstandhalter
und natürlich auch Lokomotivführer also
die ganze Breite der direkten
Eisenbahner und Eisenbahner die zu über
90% im Schichtdienst und unregelmäßigen
Schichtdienst unterwegs sind und das ist
eine besondere Belastung vor allem der
unregelmäßige Schichtdienst ist eine
besondere Belastung äh und da darüber
hinaus muss man auch noch sagen dass die
Belastung innerhalb der vor allem der
deutschen bahnag besonders hoch ist weil
dieser Bahnvorstand ja nicht nur in den
Tarifverhandlungen schwierig ist unsere
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und ich habe ja
selbst 99 meine Ausbildung mal beendet
erleben eigentlich ihr ganzes
berufslegen lang dauerhaft Überstunden
weil der Bahnvorstand selber überhaupt
nicht die richtige Logistik herbeiführt
dass dieser Betrieb funktioniert das
Erleben ja auch Kundinnen Kunden jeden
Tag und das ist ja in den letzten Jahren
deutlich schlimmer geworden und das
belastet alle und diese Belastung führt
dazu dass unsere Mitglieder uns den
Auftrag gegeben haben wir müssen zwei
Dinge tun erstens die Berufe entlasten
die im Betrieb arbeiten durch eine fünf
Tage Woche und zwei Tage frei und mit
der Absenkung der Wochenarbeitszeit die
Berufe deutlich attraktiver machen weil
uns verlassen in den nächsten 10 Jahren
so viele Kolleginnen und Kollegen in
Ruhestand und wir haben kaum noch
Nachwuchs die Interesse haben diese
schichtberufe überhaupt auszuüben ich
möchte mal auf die Stimmung bei uns im
Stream eingehen ziemlich ausgewogen es
gibt also zur Hälfte Verständnis zur
Hälfte Unverständnis über diesen Streik
gerade ein User Andrej nennt er sich
hier glaube ich schreibt ich stehe
definitiv auf weselskis Seite als
damaliger bahnpentler kenne ich die
Probleme da muss ein ganzer
Tapetenwechsel her da ist innerlich
alles tot da freut sich nur der Lutz
über die Boni also da werden die Boni an
die bahnvorstände kritisiert und ein
anderer Kommentar der kommt aber hier
von einem User Peter William er schreibt
es gibt keine andere Gewerkschaft die so
viel streikt wie sie GDL eine Frechheit
da die Öffentlichkeit da runter leidet
wenn Ihnen solche Kommentare begegnen
was macht das mit Ihnen als GDL sprechen
Sie darüber dass das natürlich jetzt
auch einen ganzen Rattenschwanz hat an
folgen und auch viele Menschen ja
wirklich von ihrem Streik betroffen sind
ja natürlich also wir Sprecher für
unsere Kolleginnen und Kollegen die am
liebsten natürlich nicht streiken würden
am liebsten wäre wir haben eine Einigung
mit einem Arbeitgeber der endlich
anerkennt dass die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen also seine eigenen Mitarbeiter
am an der leistungsk Grenze angekommen
sind und das nicht nur weil der Beruf an
sich ja schon belastend ist sondern weil
auch das System durch diese
Führungskräfte ja zu einer kompletten zu
einem kompletten Kollaps geworden sind
und natürlich sind wir irgendwann
gezwungen wenn die Arbeitgeberseite
blockiert und vor allem auch bei Themen
blockiert die schon längst ausgefochten
sind ja also wir haben 2014 dafür
streiken müssen und das waren richtig
lange Streiks dass wir überhaupt
Zugbegleiterin und Zugbegleiter in
Tarifverträgen abbilden die bei uns
Mitglied sind es gibt Tarifverträge für
Zug Begleiter und jetzt fängt der
deutsche Bahnkonzern wieder an die
gleichen Fragen mit uns von vorne
aufzurollen das ist das wo Klaus
weselski sagt es gibt scheinbar keine
Lernkurve
die wenn die deutsche bahnag sagt wir
schließen diese Tarifverträge nicht ab
zwingt man die Mitglieder zum Streik und
wenn ich noch eins Nachsetzen darf
unsere Mitglieder bei der Deutschen
bahnag die gucken ja über den Tellerrand
wenn 18 Betriebe 18 Unternehmen in
Deutschland mit uns Tarifverträge
abschließen manche sogar ganz ohne
Streik bei manchen musste ein der Druck
erhöht werden äh und da ist die 35
Stunden Woche Thema und die 5 Tage Woche
ist abgeschlossen dann fragt sich ein
deutsche Bahnmitarbeiter warum kriegt
mein meine Führung des größten
Logistikkonzerns der Welt ist nicht hin
mit mir das abzuschließen also für mich
was man glaube ich auch noch mal
auftröseln muss um das ganze zu
verstehen es gibt zwei konkurrierende
Gewerkschaften es gibt zum einen sie die
GDL und es gibt die wesentlich größere
EVG die hat wesentlich mehr Mitglieder
die hat sich schon mit der Bahn geeinigt
warum schaffen die das
na ja ich will jetzt die Forderungen und
die Abschlüsse der anderen Gewerkschaft
gar nicht kommentieren weil die haben
eigene Gremien die haben eigene
Mitglieder die für sich Tarifforderung
beschließen und am Ende auch Kompromisse
annehmen
unsere Mitglieder haben uns klar den
Auftrag gegeben wir müssen
arbeitszeitforderung stellen also nicht
reine endgeldforderung das Endgeld
steigen muss das ist ja jeden in diesem
Land klar die Inflation hat alle
getroffen der inflationssverlust muss
ausgeglichen werden aber das Thema
Arbeitszeit liegt unseren Kolleginnen
und Kollegen eben besonders auf dem
Herzen weil diese Kolleginnen Kollegen
überlastet sind und die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen erleben seit Jahren die letzten
vor allem die letzten 2 D Jahre nach
Corona dass immer mehr bestandskollegen
den Betrieb verlassen und sagen ich gehe
aus den Berufen mit Schichtdienst heraus
ich habe im Fachkräftemangel genug
andere Chancen in bessere
arbeitszeitsysteme zu kommen und wir
sehen gar nicht wo sollen denn die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen herkommen die
dann auch noch die Zukunft bei der
Eisenbahn verbringen wollen und deswegen
ist der Auftrag wir müssen den Schicht
Dienst attraktiver machen weil der
Schichtdienst eine Grundbelastung hat
wir werden immer nachtsarbeiten wir
werden immer am Wochenende arbeiten für
Fahrgäste Züge fahren aber dann muss
eben entsprechend auch ein Vorteil im
schichtdien stattfinden und das geht
eben nur über diese
arbeitszeitforderung es gibt noch eine
weitere Frage aus dem Stream die kommt
von User Sven Gaul der fragt sich falls
der aktuelle Streik die Deutsche Bahn
nicht zum Einlenken bringt wäre dann ein
unbefristeter Streik als nächstes
denkbar das hatte Herr wieselski noch
ausgeschlossen was glauben Sie ja das
kann ich Ihnen jetzt nicht beantworten
worden also ich gehe erstmal davon aus
wir sind jetzt bei einem sehr langen
Streik mit se Tagen der wird seine
Wirkung auf den Bahnvorstand entfalten
es natürlich traurig dass man das machen
muss aber wenn der Bahnvorstand
natürlich nur über finanziellen Schaden
scheinbar in die Bewegung kommt also
finanziellen Schaden auch fürs
Unternehmen was der Streik ja
verursachen soll dann werden wir mal
sehen wie der Druck jetzt wirkt wir
hoffen natürlich dass der Bahnvorstand
die Zeichen der Zeit endlich erkennt was
seine Belegschaft von ihm möchte und das
ist deutliche Verbesserung im Arbeits
und schichtssystem noch mal zurück zur
Stimmung bei uns im Stream will ich auch
gerne hier wieder an der Stelle Abfragen
also nach wie vor lese ich wirklich
beides Pro und Kontra hier für ihren
Streik ich lese zum einen der Streik
geht absolut zu weit sech Tage Mann und
die GDL die hat den Bogen total
überspannend findet hier jemand und dann
kommt hier aber auch von einem User
einer Userin folgender Kommentar ich bin
Bahnpendler und werde es überleben
streigt solange bis eure Forderungen
erfüllt werden dann gibt's langfristig
auch mehr nachwuchslockführer davon
profitiere ich als Fahrgast am Ende auch
sie haben das auch angesprochen das
Nachwuchsproblem vielleicht kommen wir
darauf zum Ende auch noch mal zu
sprechen also sie fürchten da um
Arbeitskräfte in der Zukunft das müsste
sich denn ändern ihrer Meinung nach um
den Job attraktiver zu machen na ja
erstmal muss man feststellen
Grundprinzip ist ja der Schichtdienst
ist einfach unattraktiver das war er
schon immer
aber die Zeiten haben sich etwas
gewandelt Schichtdienst ist für viele im
Nachwuchs noch unattraktiver geworden
den Schichtdienst werden wir nicht
abschaffen aber wähend in vielen anderen
Bereich natürlich bestimmte Dinge auch
entlastender wirken wie z.B Homeoffice
Möglichkeiten oder flexiblere
Arbeitszeiten sich einzuteilen das geht
natürlich in den direkten
eisenbahnberufen nicht der Zug hat ein
Fahrplan die Werkstatt hat ein Fahrplan
das muss alles sachgerecht zur Verfügung
gestellt werden jetzt reden wir mal über
Theorie wir wissen dass der Bahnvorstand
das nicht hinbekommt aber da müssen die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor Ort sein
wir können also weder mit anderen
Maßnahmen diese Berufe entlasten und da
setzen wir an und sagen wenn
Schichtdienst bleibt muss aber doch auch
ein Benefit für diese Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die diese Belastung auf sich
nehmen kommen und das ist mal mindestens
eine fünf Tage Woche dass man fünf Tage
arbeitet und zwei Tage frei hat wir
erleben doch die letzten Jahrzehnte das
Familie und Beruf geflügeltes Wort in
allen Bereichen in Deutschland aber wer
macht denn im schichtber im
Schichtbetrieb überhaupt irgendetwas für
die Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf
außer Sonntagsreden gab es dann nichts
also unsere Kollegen haben nichts
gespürt und deswegen haben sie auch
klare
Botschaften was sie denn möchten und wir
glauben fest daran wenn wir eine 35
Stundenwoche übrigens die ein wahlmodell
sein soll für die Kollegen es die können
auch durchaus in der 38 Stundenwoche
dann arbeiten das ist ja eine ein ein
wahlmodell was wir bieten und die
Kollegen die sagen ich bin so belastet
ich möchte 35 Stunden arbeiten können
das dann tun und damit haben wir eine
Entlastung im Vergleich zu anderen
Bereichen die e nicht in Schichtdienst
arbeiten sagt Sven Schmitte er ist der
Bezirksvorsitzende der GDL in
Nordrhein-Westfalen danke dass Sie heute
bei uns waren bitte gerne geschehen ich
habe bei uns im Stream jetzt auch gerade
Fragen zur juristischen Einordnung
gelesen genau dafür haben wir uns
eingeladen Professor gregor tüsing ist
jetzt bei uns er ist der Direktor des
Instituts für Arbeitsrecht und recht der
sozialen Sicherheit der Universität Bonn
und mir jetzt zugeschaltet hallo schön
guten Abend Herr Professor
tüsing fr jung ich grüße Sie Herr tüsing
ich habe hier direkt gelesen schon
relativ am Anfang bei uns im Stream eine
Frage die sich jetzt hier mit
auseinandersetzt das ist jetzt mit sechs
Tagen angesetzt wirklich der längste
Streik und da fragt sich ein User eine
Userin ist dieser Streik noch durch das
Grundgesetz gedeckt wie sieht das denn
wirklich rein re rechtlich
aus ob es der längste Streik ist oder
einer der längsten streike ist darüber
kann man sich Gedanken machen das ist
aber nicht so wichtig das Entscheidende
ist das
bundesarbeitsgerichtwickelt das Recht
des Streiks nicht aus einem
arbeitskampfgesetz nicht aus einem
streitgesetz sondern allein aus der
Koalition freiheit dem Grundgesetz
garantiert ist und diese
Koalitionsfreiheit ist eben
deutungsoffen und es gibt eine
entscheidungslinie der Rechtsprechung
seit vielen vielen Jahren die sagt
Streiks müssen verhältnismäßig sein das
Besondere aber ist dass wir keinen
Maßstab haben um zu beurteilen was ist
denn noch verhältnismäßig was
verhältnismäßiges werden Bahnpendler
vielleicht anders beurteilen als GDL
Mitglieder und so ist die Rechtsprechung
zu übergegangen um zu sagen na ja was
verhältnismäßig ist das entscheidet
zunächst ist einmal die Gewerkschaft
selber und nur in krassen
missbrauchssituationen in
offensichtlichen Fällen der UN dort
schreiten wir anen und ob das schon bei
sech Tagen gegeben ist das Hoch
zweifelhaft im Zweifel nicht sie haben
gerade diese Verhältnismäßigkeit
angesprochen lassen Sie uns dazu auch
mal in einen Ton reinhören ein ein on
den der gdlchef Klaus weselski heute
morgen bei uns im ZDF Morgenmagazin
gegeben hat wir müssen länger und auch
härter streigen weil das Management der
Bahn Beratungs resistent ist das ist
verhältnismäßig das ist rechtmäßig und
es ist zulässig drei Elemente die die
Gerichte geprüft haben von daher ist
unser Streik an der Stelle überhaupt
nicht angreifbar er wurde nämlich hier
auch in dem Interview gefragt weil das
hat jetzt ja auch Auswirkung auf die
Wirtschaft das wird Kosten haben wenn
auch der Güterverkehr so lange still
steht nennt es da also verhältnismäßig
ist können Sie uns das für uns noch
weiter ausführen also selbst wenn das
jetzt so massive Auswirkungen hat da
wirtschaftliche Folgen auch dran hängen
dann ist das so wie Herr weselski sagt
verhältnismäßig für ihn
zumindest was soll Herr weselsk sonst
sagen er wird natürlich sagen dass ein
Streik verhältnismäßig ist dass die
Gerichte das einschränkungslos bejahrt
hätten da muss man Fragezeichen anmachen
weil was wir hatten waren Verfahren im
sogenannten einzweiligen Rechtschutz was
heißt das die Gerichte müssen sehr
schnell vielleicht am gleichen Tag an
dem der Antrag eingereicht wurde
entscheiden ist das noch verhältnismäßig
und da kommt es nur zu einer sogenannten
summarischen Prüfung und da muss es
schon offensichtlich ins Auge springen
dass das nicht geht und diese
Offensichtlichkeit die haben die
Gerichte verneint zurecht weil man kann
einen Streik nicht ausknipsen und wieder
anknipfen nach Belieben da ist die
Zurückhaltung auch im Hinblick auf das
Grundrecht der Koalitionsfreiheit der
Gerichte schon richtig auf der anderen
Seite heißt das aber auch dass die Frage
ob ein solcher Streik tatsächlich
zulässig ist wo die Grenzen sind durch
die Rechtsprechung bislang so nicht
beantwortet wurde und das schlimme ist
ja oder das unangenehme um das bessere
Wort zu wählen das Bundes arbeitsgicht
hat immer anerkannt dass der Streik eine
scharfe Waffe ist und das soll er auch
sein aber dieser Streik soll sich soll
eben die Waffe soll erst dann gezückt
werden wenn sie wirklich erforderlich
ist und sie soll nicht auf Dritte
gerichtet werden und die Situation haben
wir momentan
die Gewerkschaft wird am Ende letztlich
doch nicht darumkmen um eine Schlichtung
das scheint mir doch sehr sicher zu sein
weil was soll sie nach diesen sechs Tage
noch tun wenn die Deutsche Bahn nicht
einlenkt dann hat die Gewerkschaft ihr
Pulver verschossen und dann wird es doch
zur Schlichtung kommen das wäre ein
klugerer Schritt gewesen wenn man das
vorher getan hätte und das dritte in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen wird dass da ein
erheblicher wirtschaftlicher Schaden
entstanden ist nicht nur für Passagiere
sondern auch für die Wirtschaft denn der
Güterverkehr ist ja auch getroffen das
muss man schon mit in seinen Blick
nehmen als Akteur der ebeno massiv in
der Öffentlichkeit auftritt und das ist
letztlich nicht nur eine Frage des
gewerkschaftlich guten Benehmens sondern
das ist auch eine rechtliche Frage zasst
die Frage hier auch bei uns im Stream
von Claudia Sonnenberg sie möchte wissen
die Urabstimmung wurde bereits
eingeleitet bevor das Scheitern der
Verhandlung erklärt wurde ist das
eigentlich
rechtmäßig da muss man ganz klar sagen
das ist rechtmäßig weil das ist eine
Erklärung der Mitglieder für den Fall
dass die Verhandlungen scheitern wenn
die Gewerkschaft dann den das Scheitern
erklärt dann ist es soweit und ob das
gescheitert ist oder nicht das kann eben
durch die Gerichte nicht überprüft
werden das ist diese eigene ein
Schätzung der Gewerkschaft und deswegen
haben wir eben diesen massive
Arbeitsniederlegung seitens der GDL und
es gibt noch mehr Fragen an Sie bei uns
im Stream Sascha Hirsch hat per Mail
sich gemeldet und schreibt warum ist es
so schockierend dass es Punkte gibt über
die die Bahn nicht verhandeln will die
Gewerkschaft kann natürlich etwas Neues
fordern we wenn die Bahn es nicht möchte
kann die Gewerkschaft sich doch darüber
doch nicht chaufieren muss der
Arbeitgeber über alles verhandeln was
eine Gewerkschaft
fordert Herr
natürlich muss es nicht keiner muss
verhandeln aber muss dann die Konsequenz
einer Arbeitsniederlegung vielleicht
gegenwertigen und es wird klug überlegt
sein ob man den Forderungen nicht doch
Entgegenkommen will um eben den
Arbeitskampf
abzuenden dann muss man aber eben auch
sehen dass bestimmte Forderungen eben
ganz schwer zu erfüllen sind und dass
die Bahn dann vielleicht zwischen Pest
und kolera wählen darf denn wenn wir ein
Problem haben genug Lockführer zu finden
dann werden diese Probleme sicherlich
deutlich verschärft wenn wir die die
Arbeitszeit reduzieren wenn gleichzeitig
de eine Lohnerhöhung gefordert wird die
nicht gering ist dann wird gleichzeitig
durch eine Reduzierung der Arbeitszeit
diese Marge der zusätzlichen
Lohnerhöhung noch mal erhöht das sind
also alles Dinge die die Deutsche Bahn
beachten muss sie hat für sich
entschieden dass sie dieser Forderung so
nicht nach hat alternative Angebote
abgegeben die GDL hat das abgelehnt das
ist ihr gutes Recht aber unter dieser
Situation leiden momentan die
Öffentlichkeit
wir sprechen oder schauen jetzt auch
noch mal auf einen
oton eine Aussage die der
Verkehrsminister die Volker Wissing von
der FDP im heute journal gegeben hat er
betont dass das Streikrecht ein hohes
Gut sei und wir hören aber rein was er
außerdem noch gesagt hat ich war die
ganze Zeit zurückhaltend aber das nimmt
jetzt Ausmaße an die so nicht mehr
hinnehmbar sind und deswegen habe ich in
aller Klarheit gesagt jetzt muss ein
Schlichtungsverfahren her mindestens
eine Mediation und vor allen Dingen muss
so schnell schnell wie möglich am
Verhandlungstisch gesprochen
werden dieses gesamte Interview kann man
heute Abend dann 2145 im heute journal
sehen oder jetzt schon online bei ZDF
heute aber jetzt mal darauf eingehend
auch die Bahn die gehört ja dem Bund
könnte die Bundesregierung eigentlich
eingreifen und den Streik
verbieten der Bundesminister hat recht
es sollte eine Verhandlung stattfinden
aber die wie die Bahn nicht den Streik
verbieten kann so kann auch der
Eigentümer der Bahn nicht den Streik
verbieten was an der Kritik von Volker
wiissing richtig ist es es gut wenn man
verhandeln würde aber solche Verhandlung
erreicht man als Bundesminister nicht
dadurch dass man in der Öffentlichkeit
dazu auffordert vielleicht kann man das
aber es wäre dann etwas ein freiwilliges
Entgegenkommen viel mehr gefragt ist der
Gesetzgeber Verantwortung die Hand zu
nehmen und ein Streikrecht zu schaffen
ein streikgesetz nicht für alle Fälle
der
arbeitskampfniederlegung aber doch dort
wo eben diese besondere Bereich
betroffen ist der die öffentlich ganz
maßgeblich tangiert man kann
arbeitskampfregelung als Gesetzgeber
formulieren und das Ausland macht das
vor wo dass längere ankündigungsfristen
stattfinden dass ein Notdienst in
großzügerem Ausmaß stattfindet als
bislang vor allem die Einigung zum
Notdienst einfacher wird und dass man
bevor man in einem Bereich wie Bahn wie
krank wie vielleicht auch
Kindergarten kindertageststätten bevor
man da streigt dass man den Versuch
einer Schlichtung gemacht hat nicht die
zwangsschlichtung dass das was am Ende
rauskommt verbindlich ist für beide
Seiten aber doch dass man bis zu einem
schlichterpruch und wenn der
schlichterpruch dann nicht akzeptabel
ist für eine der beiden Seiten dann mag
man die scharfe Waffe zücken und dem
Arbeitskampf seinen Lauf lassen aber
erst dann bis dahin hat man eben es
geschafft versuchen zu verhandeln und
das kann manchen Arbeitskampf dann am
Ende überflüssig machen da müsste der
Gesetzgeber handeln und dafür bedarf es
politischen Mut mehr Mut als eines
Interviews in der Tagesschau im heute
journal die jetzt weiter noch zu
Kommentaren genau andereer genau
konkurren genau also noch mal zu
Kommentaren hier direkt bei uns im
Stream Matthias Bunge hat kommentiert er
schreibt es wird bereits länger
gestreigt als verhandelt wird Herr
weselski hat von Anfang an auf
Konfrontation gesetzt krass dass er
nicht gestoppt wird Michael Schmidt
schreibt hingegen solange der Vorstand
jedes Jahr die Taschen voller Macht
durch extra Boni solange sollte die GDL
auch streiken ich finde das super und
Gundula berglar schreibt die Forderung
nach der 5 Tage Woche im Schichtdienst
ist verständlich und notwendig streigt
also wirklich hier sehr unterschiedliche
Meinungen bei uns im Stream sprechen wir
noch mal über einen einen Punkt den wir
am Anfang der Sendung auch schon hatten
es gibt also zwei konkurrierende
Gewerkschaften bei der Bahn GDL die
jetzt gerade streigt und eben diese
wesentlich größere EVG die EVG die hatte
sich auch bereits angesprochen mit der
Bahn geeinigt aber normalerweise gibt's
doch ein Tarif einheitsgesetz in
Unternehmen das einen Tarif dann für
alle vorsieht warum gilt das jetzt hier
nicht das tarifeinheitsgesetz gilt das
tarifinheitsgesetz war ein Gesetz was
man vor einigen Jahren geschaffen hat
gerade um einen Interessenausgleich
zwischen den verschiedenen
Gewerkschaften zu erreichen das führt
dazu dass immer die
mehrheitsgewerkschaft den relevanten
Tarifvertrag abschließt aber die GDL ist
eben in einigen als Gewerkschaft
undofern darf sie auch für diesen
Bereich streiken es kommt eben drauf an
wo habe ich die Mehrheiten und die EVG
ist sicherlich insgesamt die größere
Gewerkschaft aber sie ist es eben nicht
in jedem Betrieb und in jeder
Berufsgruppe und deswegen kann ich auch
ab und zu ein GDL Tarif Vertrag
durchsetzen kann im Übrigen als das
Gesetz damals verabschiedet wurde hat
man ausdrücklich gesagt in der
Entscheidung
heingeschrieben einflusst nicht
arbeitsk die äh als
Auswirkung sehen wollte man war zu
vorsichtig vielleicht auch allzu
vorsichtig das heißt das hat im
Arbeitskampfrecht nichts gebracht und
das ist eben die Situation in die wir
heute hineingeraten sind wir hatten
gerade kleinere Tonaussetzer ich habe
sie trotzdem verstanden ich versuch es
noch mal mit einer Frage zum Schluss
hoffentlich hält die Verbindung zu ihnen
die Frage kommt von Anton der fragt sich
also zum Thema Tarif was sagen sie zu
der Frage ob die GDL überhaupt Tarif
fähig ist er nennt hier ein Stichwort
und zwar fairtrain das ist eine
fairtrain müssen wir vielleicht kurz
erklären also die Verleih logführer an
andere Unternehmen darunter eben
theoretisch auch an die Deutsche Bahn
und sie soll dann diese geliehenen
logführer im besten Fall für mehr Geld
einkaufen als sie festangestellt bei der
Bahn verdienen würden so und was würden
sie aber da dem User Anton antworten was
sagen sie zu dieser Frage ist die GDL
tariffähig einige Frage die ich mir auch
schon gestellt habe die sich momentan
aber auch die Gerichte stellen denn die
Bahn hat eine Klage erhoben eben nicht
im einzweigen Rechtsschutz sondern eine
Feststellungsklage äh die ganz regulär
prüfen soll ist sie noch tariffähig das
Argument was die Bahn vorbringt und das
ist neu weil die Situation neu ist hier
ist dass wir immer schon gesagt haben
eine Gewerkschaft muss unabhängig vom
Arbeitgeber sein weil sonst ist der
Tarifvertrag nichtsswerert den sie
abschließt die Frage ist gilt das auch
andersrum dass eben eine Gewerkschaft
nicht organisatorisch verflochten werden
darf mit einem Arbeitgeber den sie
vielleicht dominiert und dadurch
Einfluss auf ihr Gegenüber gibt dazu
haben wir keine Rechtsprechung dazu
haben sich die Gerichte nicht geäußert
und weil wir eben kein
tariffähigkeitsgesetz haben weil wir
kein arbeitskampfgesetz haben ist das
eine ungeklärte Frage die Deutsche Bahn
hat wide Argumente sichere Argumente die
auf jeden Fall erfolgreich sein werden
das ganz sicherlich nicht insofern
warten wir mal mit Spannung ab was die
Gerichte sagen werden das Problem was
wir haben ist das kann eine ganze lange
Zeit dauern und dann kann am Ende
vielleicht rauskommen die GDL ist gar
nicht tariffähig und dann werden alle
Tarif geschlossen hat auch unwirksam und
dann werden auch die
arbeitsskampfmaßnahmen die sie ergriffen
hat rechtswidrig das ist schon ein
erhebliches Risiko mit dem die Deutsche
Bahn hier droht ob es sich am Ende real
das wissen wir nicht aber ein Risiko
besteht auf jeden Fall die Einschätzung
von Professor Grigor tüsing vielen Dank
dafür heute abend
danke ich danke ihnen danke auch an euch
für eure aufmer keit das Thema das wird
uns ja jetzt alle noch eine Weile
begleiten wird also mit Sicherheit auch
wieder hier bei heute live eine Rolle
spielen für heute Abend erstmal vielen
Dank und bis zum nächsten Mal gerne
tschüss